Thank you for joining us today!
My name is BradleyKnapp, and I'm one of the product managers
here at IBM Cloud
and we've come to answer the question:
what is Site Reliability Engineering, or SRE?
And SRE is really the name for a new discipline
that's actually an old discipline.
It's a new name, it's only been around 15, 18 years,
butthe job itself has been around for a very long time.
It's just evolved over time,
and now we'vegiven a formal name to the discipline and the job.
And so, the question is, what is SRE,
what is site reliability engineering?
And so, the way that I like to describe it
is that it's really the collision of the
traditional IT role and DevOps, right?
So, back in the day, in the traditional IT
role, you would think about
lots of people sitting in an operations center staring at very
large screens,
kind of arranged in a semicircle, like a mission center, or a
watch center in the military.
Well, that world doesn't so much exist anymore,
and in the new world, in the DevOps cycle
that everyone should be embracing for their softwarereleases,
you still have to have reliability.
Your developers are still going to engineer
the software to be reliable,
but when it comes to actually operating it actually delivering
the service that goes out to the end customer,
that's really kind of outside of theresponsibility of those software developers.
That's where SRE comes in.
An SRE iswhat I like to call a 50/50 role, right?
SREs should spend about 50% of their time
focusing on solving customer issues.
That can beescalations, could be responding to incidents,
dealing with an upset customer who
needs help on a tactical problem.
That's going to be 50, and then the other 50%
is maybe the most important part, and
that's every SRE should be actively
trying to automate themselves out of a job.
They want to automate all of the things.
The buzzword for this is reducing toil
, right? Reducing all of the manual work
necessary to keep any kind of
software environment up and running.
This includes the hardware itself,
it includes all of the middleware,
it includes the software - all of the related
services you have to keep these things live.
And so, the question then becomes: all right,
well, we're going to automate these things,
isn't that putting my job at risk
if we get rid of these manual tasks?
And the answer is: in reality, no it's not.
It's never going to put your job at risk,
because every time you automate something,
you gain some additional insight
into the system. Every time you automate
something, you learn something new,
and you identify additional tasks that
you'll be able to automate in the future.
And so, automation is core. It's approaching
operations with a development mindset,
because you want to programmatically
solve problems so that you don't have
to go in and make the same manual
fix time after time after time.
This is key to the SRE role, and
it's key to your success in it.
And so that other 50% of the time I talked
about that before right, that's going to be
escalations. It's going to be on-call work or,
in some cases, for a large enough
organization, SRE might be 24-7.
It's going to include customer facing work, right?
You are going to have to interact with customers,
and it's going to include being the
source of knowledge for your group.
Because SRE crosses all boundaries: it
knows about hardware, it knows about
software, it knows about monitoring, it knows
about logging, it knows about automation.
And so, they understand all of the different
components. They have the institutional knowledge
of how to keep the product up
and running as a product manager.
I like to make the joke that when I want
to know how software's designed to run,
I go, and I ask the developers who wrote it.
When I want to know how it actually runs,
I go, and I ask SRE because they're the ones who
get to deal with the implementation every day.
And so, bridging the gap between what
actually happens and what we want to happen,
that's so important to the SRE job because
they have day-to-day hands-on interaction
with how people actually use the product.
So, SRE is constantly feeding data back
into development so that development can
make the software better, at the same time that
they're automating in all of the resiliency.
SRE understands that failure will happen.
Failure is just the nature of business.
You cannot design a perfect system.
And so, what SRE excels at is
programmatically identifying
potential failures and solving them ahead
of time, and it's also good at identifying
how are we going to solve
immediate tactical problems.
And so, I talked a minute ago about monitoring,
right? That traditional IT room with all of the
screens. Well, monitoring and logging
are just key to the SRT role, SRE role.
So SREs, as they monitor, they're keeping track
of what's happening in real time. Logging is an
archive of everything that's happened, so
that you can go back and examine it later.
So, your monitoring is going to give
you the ability to anticipate failures
and see them coming so that
you can proactively solve them.
Logging is when you get an unanticipated
failure. It allows you to go back
see what happened. You can do a an RCA, a Root
Cause Analysis , on it and figure out how to
solve it, not just for now, but for the future.
That gets back into the automation again, right?
If you know what happened,
and you know why it happened,
you can then adjust that monitoring that we
were talking about, so that the monitoring
itself will catch this edge case and you
don't encounter that failure ever again.
So, SRE is just core to a successful business,
and most companies will find they have a role
pretty similar to SRE today in the world
of software in the world of technology it's
something that we already have, even
though we may not be calling it SRE,
but if you're talking to a startup, a very
young company, they're going to say, well,
you know we don't have the budget to go out
and develop an SRE organization to start with,
right? We only have 25 employees, we
only have 30 employees , and that's okay.
The important part of SRE for a small company is
not so much having someone with that job title,
because your developers are your operators at
that point. It's engineering everything they do
with that SRE mindset: that failure is an option
and, as a matter of fact, should be predicted for,
but is something that you can automate
to solve. It's something that you can
create enough redundancy that,
when failure does happen,
it's not a big deal because you're
resilient enough that nothing goes down.
And so, as long as you develop with that SRE
mindset in mind, and you are being resilient,
you're being redundant, you are constantly going
back and automating problems so that you don't
have to manually fix the same thing over and over
and over again, and you're doing good root cause
analysis on actual failures so that they don't
happen again, and you're monitoring so that you
will know when they're about to happen and you can
head it off at the pass - that's really the key.
Large organizations, they can afford an entire
SRE department. They can stand it up, or they
can transition an existing operations group into
it by empowering that operations group. Again
that 50/50 rule, spending
half their time automating,
half their time fixing problems, and automating
all of the things. Automate everything, because
the less manual work and manual intervention you
have the happier that SRE team is going to be.
Thank you so much for your time today. If you
have any questions, please drop us a line below.
If you want to see more videos like this
in the future, please do like and subscribe
and let us know. And don't forget: you can grow
your skills and earn a badge with IBM Cloud Labs,
which are free, browser-based
interactive Kubernetes labs,
that you can find more information
on by looking below. Thanks again!